هذا الفيديو ايضا دكتور مهند
مصطفى يعيد الى الذاكره احداث السابع من
اكتوبر نعم من حيث الصور من حيث اقتراب
مقاتلي القسام من الجندي الاسرائيلي
وشاهدنا هذا الجندي وهو قتيل او جريح في
ايدي قوات القسام هذا
مشهد يعني كان قد مر عليه شهران من القصف
ومن القتل
ومن استخدام كل ما لدى اسرائيل
من من من اله من اله الحرب ها هو المشهد
يتكرر من المسافه اقل حتى من الصفر ما اثر
ذلك على الداخل الاسرائيلي نعم دعني اقرا
ذلك على الداخل الاسرائيلي من خلال
زاويتين الزاويه الاولى هي الزاويه
السياسيه هذا المشهد اولا جاء ليقول
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي ان عناد القياده
الاسرائيليه على الاستمرار بهذه الحرب دون
توقف سوف يكبد خسائر كبيره جدا وهنا ياتي
الزاويه عسكريه ان ان القسام لا تزال
قادره على ضرب الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد اكثر
من 70 يوما من الحرب بمعنى ان الرساله
السياسيه التي يطلقها القسام للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي من خلال هذه الفيديو وبالنهايه
هذا الفيديو هدفه هو ايضا التاثير على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ال الرساله المركزيه
انه اصرار القياده الاسرائيليه على
الاستمرار في الحرب لا يعني ذلك هو ان
القسام ضعيف ولا يعني ذلك انه لن تكون
خساره لديكم على العكس من ذلك ان استمار
الحرب سوف تكلفكم خسائر كبيره جدا في صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي ولذلك عليكم ان تضغطوا
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه لوقف هذه الحرب
بمعنى انه لن لن تكون هنالك اي انتصارات
اي فوز واي انتصار للجيش الاسرائيلي في
هذه الحرب على العكس من ذلك ان استمرار
هذه الحرب سوف يكبد خسائر كبيره جدا
والدليل ان القسام لا تزال قادره على
التخطيط
العمليات فيها جانب استخباراتي فيها جانب
عملياتي فيها جانب تخطيطي وقدراتها
العسكريه
والتنظيميه لا تزال قائمه بعد 70 يوما من
الحرب ولذلك هذه الرساله تحاول ان تؤثر
على المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهل هي تؤثر طبعا
هي تؤثر بشكل كبير جدا لانه بالنهايه
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لديه الثقه بالجيش
والجيش يسوق روايه معينه للعمليات
العسكريه في قطاع غزه هذه الفيديوهات تفند
هذه الروايه العسكريه اول مركب من مركبات
الروايه العسكريه ان حماس ض ضعفت في هذه
الحرب ان سيطرتها تراجعت ان قدراتها
العسكريه راجعت انه تم اغتيال الكثير من
قياداتها م مما اثر على معنوياتها وعلى
قدراتها العسكريه والتنفيذيه هذه
الفيديوهات تعطي انطباعا وصوره وواقعا وهل
عين المشاهد الاسرائيلي ترى هذه
الفيديوهات لان هنالك رقابه عسكريه تم كل
ذلك نعم هي نعم طبعا الرقابه العسكريه في
هذه الحرب هي الاشد في تاريخ دوله اسرائيل
ا ولكن الرقابه العسكريه لا تستطيع ان
تراقب كل هذه الفيديوهات التي تنتقل عن
طريق السوشيال ميديا عن عن طريق شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي التي يطلع عليها
المجتمع الاسرائيلي المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ينظر الى هذه الفيديوهات ويراها ولذلك
هنالك في تاثير لهذه الفيديوهات ليس فقط
على المجتمع الاسرائيلي عموما وتاييده
للحرب وايضا على العائلات الاسرائيليه
التي لديها اسر ورهاء في قطاع غزه ولذلك
هذا الفيديو الرساله السياسيه والعسكريه
الاساسيه التي يحملها انكم مصرون على
الحرب مستمرون فيها ولكن هذا الامر سوف
يكبد خسائر كبيره جدا في صفوف جيوشكم و و
جنودكم التي يعتبرهم المجتمع الاسرائيلي
زي ابناء اعتبرهم اولاد في داخل الجيش اذا
اذا هذه الفيديوهات تؤكد ان اولادكم
مستهدفون في هذه الحرب والقسام لم يتراجع
لا في قدراته العسكريه ولا التنظيميه طيب